former President Obama returned to the
public spotlight for the first time
since leaving the White House he spoke
to about 500 people yesterday at a forum
for students in Chicago mr. Obama said
he wants to empower young leaders to
become more involved in politics Dean
Reynolds is in Chicago with what the
former president said and did not say
Dean good morning
good morning well mr. Obama re-emerged
yesterday with an easygoing manner that
only a former president can appreciate
in the city where he began his political
career former President Barack Obama
vowed to help young leaders do the same
the single most important thing I can do
is to help in any way I can prepare the
next generation of leadership the 44th
president met with six young panelists
at the University of Chicago on Monday
what's been going all I've been going
with a focus on bridging the country's
deep political divide we have some of
the lowest voting rates of any advanced
democracy and low participation rates
then translate into a further gap
between who's governing us and what we
believe Obama steered clear of
mentioning President Donald Trump
there's a reason why I'm always
optimistic even when things look like
they're sometimes not going the way I
want and that is because of young people
like this his reimagines follows several
months of vacationing and decompressing
you're finally gonna get some sleep and
take some time to be with our family and
perhaps reflect ordinary people when
working together can do extraordinary
things on Monday Obama acknowledged that
his comments made at the 2004 Democratic
National Convention were largely
aspirational there is not a liberal
America and a conservative America there
is the United States of America there's
a lot more that people have in common
than divides them but obviously it's not
true when it comes to our politics and
our civic life
[Music]
now one of the people on the panel
yesterday told us that no one from mr.
Obama's team specifically requested that
he not be asked about Donald Trump
though it was assumed that he didn't
want to deal with that topic theme thank
you you're not supposed to assume but I
guess in this case yeah I think it's a
safe assumption assumption yeah